hello and welcome to ensuring quality
with IT algorithms a webinar on how the
University of Michigan laboratory
implemented patient moving averages to
raise quality and reduce costs my name
is VES awards and i'm the senior global
marketing manager at ceilings healthcare
diagnostics we have allowed time at the
end of this webinar for QA so please use
the Q&A button on the lower left hand
side of your screen to submit questions
throughout the webinar I am now honored
to introduce Nancy Haleigh who is our
moderator for this session Nancy is the
senior clinical consultant at siemens
healthcare diagnostics she is a key
member of our seamen scientific
marketing team and provides educational
seminars to customers on complex disease
states such as oncology cardiology and
infectious diseases prior to joining
siemens nancy was vice president and
director laboratory director at metlife
where she was responsible for global
testing and information nancy has
published extensively with over a
hundred and fifty articles in
peer-reviewed magazines in addition
she's written educational of chapters
are 4 and 0 15 educational chapters and
she is a recognized a specialist who has
lectured internationally on cardiology
and cancer risk we're delighted to have
her as our moderator and Nancy I will
pass this over to you
Thank You vesna and I'd like to welcome
everyone to this semen sponsored
educational seminar of course we have
goals for our seminars and the first one
today will be to accentuate what we all
know and that is that results with
questionable QC will never be released
from our laboratory that is the total
goal of any laboratory and anyone
involved in quality control our
priorities must be the quality will
always come first but will not sacrifice
on time delivery when a patient's care
is at risk the action that we will take
is that we will use predefined criteria
to guide a proactive intervention now
this is the role of quality control that
we were all taught in school and that we
implement on a daily basis but there are
ways of making this even more reliable
of helping us deliver our results more
quickly to our patients and we're very
honored today to have Eric vas binder
with us who is the chemistry automation
supervisor at the University of Michigan
Medical Center mr. vas binder has over
25 years of experience in clinical
diagnostics he brings to us his
knowledge of the automation laboratory
which is where we're all going these
days he has performed tests in his
laboratory at a level that's currently
over 9 million tests per annum running
24 7 his experience and background
includes toxicology and development of
new a safe procedures something near and
dear to my heart he has been
instrumental in reducing errors at the
university of michigan by seventy-three
percent in facing an increased volume of
very high numbers
on almost a daily basis his kept his
head count steady for the past seven
years something that we all wish that we
could do mr. Fassbinder holds a
bachelor's degree in medical technology
and a minor in microbiology for Michigan
Technical University he will be with us
today to give us the best information
available on improving moving averages
Eric I'm going to pass control over to
you and I'd like to remind our audience
to please submit questions during the
presentation and hopefully I'll be able
to address most of them at the end of
the talk hi and welcome everyone and
thanks Nancy for the very nice
introduction I'm hoping that today we
can shed a little light on moving
averages and the decisions that need to
be made when using them we've been using
them here at University of Michigan
Medical Center for going on about seven
years now with some success and I wanted
to share some of the insight and the
thought process we use and hope that
helps people with moving forward with
maybe trying to use them in this first
slide I think it's important to always
put things in context and size and type
of operation that you're running does
play a big role in using moving averages
and how you're going to try to implement
them for us here at the University of
Michigan Hospital we are serving three
hospitals 40 health centers 120
outpatient clinics we have medical and
nursing schools attached we do quite a
bit of research work that we process
through the line and also we are serving
as a reference lab as well so we have
quite a varied types of patients coming
in protesting at any given point we do
run as Nancy said about 9 million
chemistry test and amino acids a year we
are 24 7 our current configuration for
automation line has for a be 1800
chemistry analyzers attached to it and
three have you Center XPS for
immunoassays and we
been using a Centrelink for the entire
eight years as our middle work when we
talked about moving forward with moving
averages we were facing some issues
right away as we implemented automation
and we wanted some help with that so
what we were looking at was we had
rapidly increasing workloads we were
running or somewhere around four and a
half million essays per year at the
beginning when we automated 2006 and
within six months we were at about six
million tests as an average volume so
that was about twenty three percent
higher turnaround times were increasing
there was a lot of excess of QC and
patient reruns they were being used when
I say possible problems in that that you
see in the screen there that was because
text didn't always recognized was real
or not real at that point we come off of
17 years of dry slight technology and
they were very comfortable with that
when we went to wet chemistry's they
became a little less confident because
there is issues involved with that with
water and everything else and and so
they ran a lot of things over and over
again sometimes they try to get
comfortable that there was also
responses issues were delayed being new
to automation and auto validation there
was sometimes issues to try and
determine the size and scope of problems
as well so they were really kind of
having some problems and we wanted to
look at some possible solutions and
moving averages with one of the ones we
want to try so and when trying to use
moving averages we were hoping to first
of all look at tackling problem
detection we really felt that that was
significant we wanted to be able to find
problems as fast as we could and also
work on improving the tech responses we
want to minimize this year's obviously
we wanted to shorten that response time
and try to not have bad valleys go out
also we were looking to decrease the use
of QC and help minimize those reruns to
what would be appropriate and not be
excessive and if we could do those first
three things we really felt that that
was going to improve the overall line
operation and improve turnaround times
see just a smoother process completely
so that's what we were shooting for us
we want to move forward kind of is
another thing to put in context when we
look at QC we're all running QC in our
labs we as you know if we look at it
types of QC that we run sometimes I can
vary a little bit though but for us
we're running our daily maintenance QC
or chemistry analyzers are run
full-blown QC twice a day we have
instrument auto generate QC so our abia
chemistry systems are running QC eight
packs which automatically from QC that's
held onboard and that can fire off at
any time of day we have issue generated
QC where text may think that they have
detected a shift or maybe they think
there's a possible problem and we all
see that and that can happen any time of
day as well and then we have our moving
average QC or what we'll call humic you
see and that is being used all the time
if we eliminate HemoCue see from that
equation we're running greater than
26,000 QC points a month and that's a
lot of QC and some of you are probably
running as much as that or more maybe
and it's a necessary function but any
time we can reduce that it has a huge
impact on the lab because obviously
there's a cost of the QC material itself
the cause of reagent tech time that's
involved and so it can be quite
significant and moving averages QC there
again if it can really minate even a
little bit of that can really play some
role in improving your operations we
also have used modified Westgard rules
we don't use all of us guard rules in
our middleware or we've eliminated the
use of 5 and 10 X rules we didn't feel
that they were necessary time we
actually have not used them for the
entire time that we've been running with
the track and we use all the rest of
them and we apply what scared rules as
welcome to moving averages so just for
kind of the fat basis that people are
not completely aware what moving
averages are they're rolling or moving
average of patient baileys that can
continuously monitor an assay of
interest first proposed in 1965 by
hopping Wade I'm not
how they dealt with things back then but
obviously middleware nowadays makes it's
much easier to employ with computers
away there now we can really track how
our asses are performing across
analyzers that's a huge gain and losing
moving averages so i'm not sure if they
had to do it by hand back down or not
but definitely things are much faster in
which easy needs now and this slide here
is so that we go for those that have
Centrelink or a middleware system just
to kind of show how easy it is to engage
it this is a screenshot of what our text
would look at when you're going to turn
on a say on and off for those that do
have centrally as you can see where the
arrows pointing they pull this up a lot
during the day and they actually can
easily check moving averages to turn on
or turn them back up this is the box
that's two boxes above that enable
reporters where they actually turn in
this case calcium on up it can be done
in just a few seconds so that makes
moving average is very easy to employ
and to disable if you don't need them at
any given point and any tech could do
this so it doesn't have to be just as
supervisor level so it's very easy
straight for to use there are two types
of moving averages we're going to be
kind of talking about there's audit or
undefined and then there's a fine where
we would actually apply a set mean and
an SD when we look at the audit if you
look across a vitamin D there at the top
you can see that we are we're not
generating points on a graph where but
we are developing or generating string
values which you can see there which are
the actual average of the 50 patients in
our case that's a 50 patient point size
that we use so you can see at the very
top on there is a 24-point 96 and that
would be that erage of 50 previous
patients more importantly or as
important i should say we are also
generating a timestamp and that's at
assessed time right there that tells me
when that point was generated this is
very important as we utilize them for
troubleshooting purposes or two
be able to determine when points happen
and when things have deviated so
timestamps are very important as you can
see you're seeing it's called human QC
by a lot species that's why we kind of
call only averages are human
interchangeably one thing about vitamin
D and this is where there's a great gain
and moving averages for example right
now currently we have a new like a
modified vitamin d sa that has been
given to us we've been using it now for
several weeks we have been auditing
vitamin D for actually the past two
years and continuously and so there was
some concern by a neighboring facility
to contact us and as we've seen any kind
of shift when we change into that a lot
and I was able to quickly look within
just a few minutes of five minutes to
look back at the previous two weeks
before we engage see what the averages
are run look at the two weeks since
we've been engaged and tell that there
was no impact whatsoever even though QC
had shifted a little bit the moving
averages for patients had actually
elevated slightly which was normal for
this time of year actually in Michigan
we're getting a little bit more Sun now
a little warmer weather so we're going
to start seeing those the values
increase on but but this is where audits
actually play a great role and then
defined as you can see down below with
calcium we're actually generating points
on a graph and using a Westgard graph
there and we can actually at that point
because we're using set means and SDS we
can generate flags or failures using
Westgard rules and we're still
generating those string values that we
can see them can see the timestamps as
well but but that at that point that's
the gain in that is that you can get
reaction from your texts and stuff so
there's two type sir that will be
talking about and just again to show how
easy it is to kind of modify things in
here this is the screens that we would
pull up normally to set our means and
SDS for in this case we're looking at
calcium and so this is where we normally
go in for my my normal QC adjustments
and as you can see the line that's kind
of high layout to the right that's
calcium a human and so I would just
right click bring up this box put in a
target and a deviation for one
d and say okay and that would employ
immediately at that point you're 50
points would be generating with the West
guard rules applied to it and this only
takes a very short time to do this and
it's very easy to go in and modify it
again and again as you need to so it
really is a great tool to use so you can
make adjustments and you can improve
upon your processes as you have more
data to work with and refine it to what
works for you so just kind of wanted to
show how easy it is it's very
straightforward it does not take a lot
of time to learn how to use this there's
a lot of decisions though that we want
to look at when we're using moving
averages and and some of these are going
to be intertwined into each other but to
kind of real quickly what we're going to
be talking about its audit versus to
find what is the goal that we're trying
to achieve with moving averages but we
don't want to just generate data for
nothing we want to be able to use it for
something and we're already kind of
overwhelmed in today's society with the
amount of data that we're given so we
want useful information what assays ever
going to monitor we monitor them all do
we monitor just a few that's something
to look at what patient populations are
we monitoring are we talking about a
mixed population from a hospital we're
talking about a reference lab population
where it's more outpatient type or those
que native impacts are what size to use
for each point how big how many points
out patients do you want into each point
is going to have a lot of impact on how
things or play if defined how tightly
are we going to monitor so how old they
are gonna make those that's deets when
do we want the responses refer if we
want absolute failures do we want flags
comes less something look at as well and
how are we going to react to the
information that we gain that's really
one of the most important things that
kind of reinforce that at the end of
this as well that we're developing
rating this information we want our text
to react accordingly to how we want them
to be seen you know what we want them to
do with it and and that will help with
the whole process and improve the
quality of the results that you're
putting out so we'll be looking at as
well now in
had an audit versus the defined decision
first of all for audit as we kind of had
said in the previous vitamin D example
that it gives action points for possible
issues we had those time stamps it
allows for instrument to instrument
comparisons to monitor operations I
think that is one of the biggest gains
and moving averages for me having
multiple platforms especially in case of
chemistry analyzers having for chemistry
analyzers on the line especially for the
common test you know so your basic comes
essays in there that you're going to use
the poor you're going to basically be
able to use an audit to to see how all
four platforms are operating in a
real-time sense and that's really a huge
game and and its really where I get a
lot of value from it now it's a it's a
audits are a passive monitoring they
don't really require responses so as you
saw there was no action points in there
or no doubts I should say so there's no
engagement of Westgard rules and so this
makes it easy to start with here when
you talk about moving averages i would
suggest starting with audits anyway
that's what we did as well you kind of
get a feel for the text don't have to be
trained at this point they can you can
just turn it on kind of see what kind of
baileys you can generate and then you
can make decisions from there and apply
some of the decision tree to how you
want to refine that then in a defined
moving average we're getting it as well
the instrument comparisons and the
action points that we were getting from
the audit but we're getting those QC
notices and we're holding results if
it's severe enough that's really a huge
gain when you decide to make that jump
to the fine not every essay may be
perfect for that though and texts are
going to be actively engaged at that
point you're going to have to train them
somewhat to how the response is going to
be here to have talks with how you're
applying it and so not that it's a big
deal but but you definitely want their
involvement and make sure that they're
you're on the same page as you move
forward with defining we actually use
both and we use some essays for audits
and some / 2 pi that's something as we
talk more about it some more decisions
here in a second it'll make a little
more sense
as to what you would choose this is an
example of a chloride audit in use and
this is really how I like to look at it
in terms of this is looking at all four
of my chemistry analyzers looking at
chloride over a five hour time frame on
it's moving from top to bottom / wound
through that in a linear fashion through
time and you're seeing an audit of
chloride being applied at the same time
that we're seeing real QC being
generated by the text as they are doing
different operations on the system if
you look at it to the right hand side in
the blank spaces you where you don't see
the dots those are your audit points and
as we do is we kind of look over to the
string Bell you can see that the four
analyzers as you wrap down that list or
generating wealth eyes and 106 and so
all for the analyzers are generating
moving averages within blonde of each
other for chloride and actually as you
move forward with moving averages you're
going to find out more than you might
think that your your essays are going to
average out very close together from
point to point it is actually very
amazing and makes it very good for being
a little track so right there I can kind
of tell all four platforms are operating
exactly the same at this point we also
can see that the real QC being laid out
with it is within plus or minus 1 St for
the most part and and so there was any
question about chlorides right now I
feel like the analyzers are operating
correctly I have a very good confidence
in this text to is well when they look
at it this way but but it's very easily
to modify this you could just see the
audit if you want just you need to see
it so you can play around and then have
what you want you can click on the
different columns and move it around so
you don't have to see it stack out in
this kind of time fashion but for me
this is what works about so just I'm
gonna give you guys an idea now when we
talk about what asses to choose probably
the most important decision in that
question is not on this list and that
would be what s is giving you the most
problem and that's where we chose to
start with we decided to get the most
paying for this reference right away and
that was to go for in our case calcium's
when we went to web chemistry's we
a different water system than we do now
we had quite a few pH changes that were
happening from day to day we were seeing
or calcium bellies drip canoeing to be
readjusted recalibrated or blanked to
control that before we really kind of
had an idea with moving averages that
was kind of creeping up outside of times
and the text wouldn't notice this shifts
happening and then by the time they did
they that's going to make correction so
we just started to tackle calcium first
and we started with an audit and we did
for several months and then kind of look
at how we were responding to them and
they make decisions from there but some
assays may be too broad ranged when
you're looking at your choices won't
talk about tumor markers enzymes you
know in case of c125 maybe you have
patients that are coming in and there
are in the hundreds or maybe low
thousands but then maybe you're going to
intermittently have patient that's
125,000 and if you're trying to use a
defined range then you may see these
large shifts occur that may cause text
to be alarmed when it's really just a
normal patient value for that patient
not a good value but but still that is
what it is you know same thing can have
all the enzymes there can be a lot of
movement so some assays may work to
audit they may not work to be defined
and it is definitely come back SI by si
case when we look at calcium's or
sodium's are really most of the your
normal basic and comp essays usually
here you have much tighter normal ranges
and so it becomes much easier to set a
defined range in both calcium and sodium
are audited in a defying value place
continuously actually over the last six
seven years we've been doing it and they
work very well and we're able we were
able to tweak those ranges in and get
the proper responses we want from text
from and so they're very helpful in that
way but but that's definitely what you
want to kind of look at you know some
assays you may say it's just not
feasible or or giving you the data that
you want or if it's too broad range now
how frequently performed is another
question to kind of look at in our case
we run about 25 CA is a day not that
many we're using a 50 point average and
if i was going to generate a point every
two days does it really
a lot of value to know that two days ago
I might add a problem and one hand you
can say yes it's nice to know that but
but in a constant real-time kind of
sense of trying to be able to resolve
issues is there a lot of gain from it
vitamin DS on the other hand we run
about 250 a day quite a few and I can
generate five points a day five or six a
day and I can kind of compare across
platforms are two platforms wanting that
sa and I get more but like I said a real
time sense of what's actually occurring
and that last question are they I'm one
or multiple analyzers as I kind of
stated for me I'm i like the essays that
are more analyzers they function very
well on one but I get more valley when
I'm applying them to the multiple
analyzers for that real-time sense of
what's happening with the instruments in
patient populations um this is where a
reference lab would have one complete
type of population only where an
outpatient world there can be much more
consistent much more easily adapted to
having to find ranges for more assays
when we talk about a mixed population in
a large facility like we have here then
we have some issues that occur and
inpatient versus outpatient is one of
them calcium is a perfect example of
this and that in the morning we average
around 7.5 to nine-point-oh millions per
deciliter for the calcium's and so on
the low side because of dietary
restriction etc illness but then any
afternoon as we get our outpatient work
our reference work starts coming in then
we start averaging nine point over 10.5
so how do you apply that then in a sense
of save defined range which we have done
took a you know some time and some
effort and tweaking with it but but it
plays very well now but but that's
something you got to look at because
those shifts as they occur may cause
failures or flags to occur in cab your
checks reacting to them in define sense
maybe an audit works better but in our
case to find work very well show you
example and second year but as far as
ers and I see you here's where we're
starting to talk about again with
certain assays that you're going to have
patients that are going to have very
high values or very low values as
they're obviously much sicker on a real
they these values could generate flags
in a single patient maybe they could be
that extreme and so how do you want to
react to that and they're getting
defined vs audit comes into play here's
is it's an assay that if you're going to
have a lot of these um is that going to
cause a problem or causing excessive
amount of tech response cancer and
cardiac centers another or specialty
clinics in our case our Cancer Centers
of cardiac center send roughly 20 to 25
tubes at a time and these inner dumps
that we get and and as you put those all
to a line at once then sometimes you're
going to see these patients up similar
illnesses like in case of multiple
myeloma different tumor markers
obviously are going to be elevated at
different times from clinics and so then
you're going to see shifts occur at that
and so how do you incorporate those as
well so that's one of the things you
want to really kind of use when you're
trying to make decisions about essays
patient populations and what that impact
again auditing for some time before you
apply it or do further work within a
defined sense is probably the preferred
way to do that this is an example I was
talking about for calcium bearing
between shifts um we initially had
tighter ranges that had more issues but
here you can see at this point we're
applying a 9.1 target Bailey to calcium
and as you look at this and this is just
looking at human moving averages this is
not any other kind of QC you can see
that and this is over a couple days time
on one instrument you can see that in
the afternoons as getting those 2120 300
time frames as we're getting all our
outpatient you can see this does
shifting to the right as we generate 9.4
9.5 averages and then you put you can
also see that in the center there you
can see that in the middle or no morning
run where it's all inpatient primarily
that we generated 8.8 so for us as we
did our audit for those several months
we kind of saw where we had real
failures occur and then we were applied
ranges that would kind of encompass that
our texts know that they shouldn't see
any 8.8 3.9 s and the afternoon they
also know they should be seeing 9.4 in
the morning because they're very used to
the patient population as we move on so
this makes it
much easier for them to to track and to
help understand when things are going
off the tracks and when they're having a
problem so it's it's very useful in that
case but but like I said four different
sites you may want to do different
things but thrust calcium works very
well on the defined range what size
should each average be I you know we're
using a 50 point average for us that
that has worked well it makes sense here
in a second as we talk about this but if
it's too small um we have an issue with
that and that they may overreact a
single point deviation or patient
deviations uh or shifts in population as
we're kind of talking about it from your
clinics and things like that um there's
also the issue with uh you know critical
values and very extreme bellies are
normally repeated and if you repeat them
if one patients possibly going to cause
a shift then maybe that repeat if it's
the same analyzer or moving to a
different analyzer may cause more
concern from the text you know as it may
push the point higher it may cause
another incident to flag and then they
start and chasing wild fires here that
aren't really true so it's it's
important not to make it too small again
it's something we really kind of kind of
try play with if it's too big it may
take too long to generate much like we
talked about if the point if the number
of samples you're performing or too
small that case your days to generate
same kind of thing here it may take too
long to generate point so that you don't
respond fast enough to an issue and we
don't want them to underwrite two issues
as well we want that that quicker
response so i definitely would suggest
that when you first try to move forward
with moving averages that you look at
your audits and you could try different
sizes you could maybe try buck 25 points
eyes and then maybe after a week or two
try a 50-point size and kind of see what
the impact is on those averages that
you're jamming the actual numbers and
and how fast things are happening and
then you can make decisions from an area
and at some point you may be land
different sizes as well I think the size
the institution we really play a role in
this as well that smaller institutions
could use smaller point sizes larger
institutions there
pumping through valleys much faster
we're going to want those bigger point
sizes for me at a 50-point sighs we're
generating a point about and are busy
times a day around every 35 to 40
minutes or so and they also are big
enough to encompass somewhat a little
bit of a patient issue so if a patient
we do get an elevated patient and if
it's not too elevated it won't cause a
flag if we get an extreme patient in
where there's been an issue with a
contaminated sample or something
obviously it is going to generate
something and then we would investigate
that but the deciding on appropriate
standard deviations is very similar to
the point size issue in that too small
to big is going to cause some concerns
it is as a dependent obviously tumor
markers again enzymes seems like they
have much bigger cbss can use to them
then some of your other essay so you're
definitely going to look at it SI by si
it will require some trial and error
this is where the screen I showed you
where you can apply your s DS and means
comes in because once you've generated a
few weeks worth of data it's very easy
to go in apply a mean and SD see how
many points failed I say okay take note
of that go back in adjust your SD or
slightly see how many points failed now
and then you can kind of tweet this so
once you have data it's very easy going
and manipulate things and kind of
perfect what you want to do with them
and they are again that's why audits or
the way probably to start before you
move in to defined moving averages this
is an example for the standard
deviations that where we kind of talked
about it's too tight to too large and so
I kind of took that calcium data that
you had seen earlier where everything
was okay but they were shifting slightly
in here you can see that I had a point
to to SD applied earlier an example that
I'd shown you and here we're seeing a
point 15 sold by point 07 I tighten that
up and you can see now that I generated
five failures Oh number one and actually
at the bottom of that top set of data
you can see that I have a failure and a
number to instrument
in the morning room as well so if I
applied that logic across the four
platforms I'd have just on one assayed
have 20 failures a day if that was going
to be ever so that that's too many
obviously and in this case here when we
know that we have a failure like this
happening and we once we determine that
this is actually maybe cause like in
this instance this is probably caused
just by a patient population shift as
you can see the times are increasing
they're getting more into an out patient
load once we determined that then we
would expect maybe the next point to be
elevate is well and not respond in the
same fashion we which the initial point
reset it watch for the next one and then
we really be looking for this shift if
it was to continuously move higher we
would react differently look at blanking
calibrating etc to try and push it in
but if it was in the morning it'd be a
different instance we would respond
immediately looking at making a
correction to the essay but you'll
notice that there again as I said that
that bottom then number two instruments
showed that 8.8 flag as well in the
morning because as we look at the bottom
set of data and we look at the SD of
being point three so point oh wait
higher than what I had before now all
the data is in the green that's good
everything's within two SD but but more
importantly now that you made the main
too big if you look down at the bottom
at that one that number to point at
eight point eight is not only not in the
yellow or not flagging now it's down and
plus or minus one st and text them to
think everything is rosy as long as it's
all moving in a green so you don't want
that you want them to actually see
things maybe as it's moving down this is
a downward trend that we really want to
see that maybe our next point was to be
eight point seven or in moving lower now
we're starting to see a patient impact
so we want to be able to respond
correctly to that so you really gotta
can't play around dealing with moving
average failures as I said was is very
important in this case we're looking at
a patient being validated here at the
top and so we see that there's a QC
severity out to the right at us column a
green one which means that this is the
first time flag of a Westgard or failure
and pay our texts are trained right away
to to see that when they see it they
immediately
he will click to that and look to the QC
for that instrument as you can see it's
instrument number one ought to the right
and and they would then determine at
that point that it was a human QC
failure and they would contact the
operators who would then take the tests
offline they would immediately ask
request for real QC to be run that takes
five minutes for that calcium assay to
occur in the meantime they would quickly
look at when the point generated to win
the previous point generated that in in
the middle where systems you should be
able to pull up those patients very
quickly and they are able to hear in
this example and look at 50 patients
click through them real quick to see is
just an overall increase as this caused
by a single patient deviation it's a
single patient they're not going to be
concerned about it and the QC was just
being run just to check but if there was
a everything he's shifting higher than
they would at that point have the QC
comin out 15 minutes to tell them that
the instruments actually in control or
not and they can respond correctly and
pakusa comes back find end day it's okay
these are just patient populations
moving up from outpatients or something
and and and everything would be resolved
quickly so stressing importance of
recognition is really can't be
under-estimated you really want the text
to know what to do to see it quickly and
you wanted to find a standard reaction
so failures that's what we've kind of
dummy we wrote actually when we started
this process as we moved along and we
realize that first what are we doing
failures that we kind of wrote like a
two page summary just for calcium try to
respond to them and and kind of work
with the text and and and then as it
says here at the bottom review responses
so as we then apply those rules we went
back later and say okay so in this case
we corrected five patients and we caught
it fast and faster than before but but
what could we do to catch it even faster
we look at what the texted and and how
we reacted and then we make some tweaks
of that and now we've got this down to
where we we a lot of times don't correct
any patients we don't have to we've
gotten a response is better we can catch
things very quickly so it's really
important to have designed response and
and then make sure that everybody's
aware what it is that you want and then
you really going to get the most value
for your effort here so things to kind
of keep in mind with moving average is
that there's there are quite a few
benefits you're going to get tighter
control of your acid performance and
that's really what I get mostly now we
don't have as many issues with patients
and I get a lot more of that monitoring
across my platforms you get faster and
better responses to issues on the text
definitely jump right away when they see
that and they know there might be an
issue and they investigate there's
definitely a cost savings on real QC
material and tech time that we don't
want as much we don't excessively repeat
things like we need to it's easily
stopped and started as I told you in the
beginning you could you can turn this on
in a few minutes in a minute you can
turn it off just as easily whenever you
want and so it's something that you can
apply as need it so you can say hey alts
are acting up today made me a little
audit them for a little bit just kind of
make sure that the instruments are
somewhat i behaving the same or any is a
and and that we use that in that fashion
quite a bit um just to kind of see how
things are going uh it but it's really
important to note that this is just one
piece of the puzzle moving averages are
not going to solve all your problems or
any of your all your issues together but
if applied correctly it is going to be
one tool and your QC belt your your
ability to improve your operations and
and so if it's well thought out it
definitely is a help some effects to
remember though it's not utilized
properly that data data overload can
occur as I said you can get that forest
through the trees effect that if you're
generating a lot of points excessively
and you're not doing stuff the text can
kind of be kind of overwhelmed and get
to a point where they won't react
properly at the time when it's really
needed and then also if the you know the
whole idea of overreaction to false
issues ranges are too tight you don't
want your text jumping every five
seconds to investigate things that are
kind of pseudo issues caused by a single
patient and stuff so that's somewhere
there again a little thought and how you
apply your define ranges will go a long
ways
so kind of looking back at how we did
how did we know what was our gain and
using moving average as well as Nancy
kind of set in beginning errors have
been reduced by gradient 7% you
definitely have much faster resolutions
we our issues are greatly minimized in
size and scope we were before we might
have had 10 15 maybe Flags a week when
we are applying just for calcium's as we
got better with both applying these
rules and and and adjusting them the
stuff now we basically have it set to a
point where we may be only see those
flags one or two times a month on just
that assay our water system has been
changed this definitely hit played a lot
of roles and is too but but we the tech
response is fantastic when we actually
do have a live even with fewer plagues
coming they know what to do right away
they see it they they they jump to it
right away and it's been fantastic our
QC use just has improved dramatically I
can't really give you hard numbers that
but I do know that we ordered a year to
a year and a half batches at a time and
the QC that we use for the automation
line last now for a month or two months
longer than what it used to so that's a
big deal for the amount of QC that we
use so it has helped greatly um
turnaround times definitely improved if
you look at those bottom numbers it's
fantastic the stat which we want to get
her stats out under 45 minutes you can
see in 2006 when we started and I told
we are having trouble with our
turnaround times that we were only
meaning our expectation around seventy
five percent which we were not happy
with on now or is it last year we were
at 99.1 percent or even better not we
just had our best month ever last month
which was somewhere around nine point
eight percent for the stats and even
looking at that we initially set failure
rates back in two thousand six we wanted
to set no more than five percent to be
outside of 45 minutes and we actually
proved it to listen to three percent
since then the text bought completely
into this whole idea of trying to
improve things and understood what
moving averages are helping though
they're getting moving air
which is alone didn't do this but but
they played a huge role in helping us
move forward so it's really been
worthwhile and I've really been happy
with what we got out of them and I can't
want to leave you this before we get
back to Nancy here but this Court I
thought was perfect for the discussion
we just kind of had a moving average
that quality is never an accident is
also result of high intention sincere
effort intelligent direction and
skillful execution and it represents a
wise choice of many alternatives and
that was by William Foster and it
definitely plays in the all the
decisions you have to make moving
averages in and the role that plays and
in the effort they have to put into it
so I just really thought it was
appropriate there so I'm going to turn
it over to Nancy now for questions so
hopefully that helped thank you Eric it
really did help and I hope that our
audience appreciated the amount of
effort that you've put in to having
these moving averages implemented in
your laboratory I think it's extremely
important that we understand how the
process evolved and as you said it
doesn't happen overnight it's something
that requires the buy-in of your whole
staff and the education of your staff I
think one of the things that is
extremely important to me is that you've
been able to improve the step turn
around time so that almost all of your
stats are released in less than 45
minutes and for those of us that are
involved in emergency rooms and critical
situations that becomes very important
my question and this is not from the
audience just from listening to you
today my question would be do you think
it would be helpful if you could educate
your laboratory technologists more in
the overall disease state process and
what happens such that when a patient
presents with an MI and suddenly you've
got one result which is way out of
control but it's the patient
so good clinical education for some of
our technologists actually help so that
we can maybe eliminate or greatly reduce
overreaction by the text to some oddball
result which is really very very patient
specific it's kind of a funny question
but I'll pass it to you honey first you
don't pass it to you I think it's a very
good question and that's something they
hear I work I and constantly have over
the last eight years and done that
before as well but I think every time we
have unusual patients are you know we
tend to talk about and we've made a lot
of effort to to educate them and that
kind of concern like you said to a
disease state and the kind of responses
that occur because that's exactly what
we saw in the beginning when we
initially applied them there was a lot
of overreaction since then as we they
have become more informed that makes it
much easier they look at them as they do
the reviews or 50 patient reviews they
can see that that single patient
elevated they know that's why and now
that's why the response is so much
quicker and so much easier for them and
so it really has saved a lot of that
operation and it continues to improve
daily for them and so yes that's exactly
what needs to happen it will overall
save you a lot of time thank you now
let's give to some of the more specific
questions that have come in from our
audience the first one is that you've
mentioned that your laboratory uses
modified Westgard rules eliminating the
use of five times and ten time rules
what was the basis for that decision and
now how did it improve QC performance in
your laboratory I'll turn it back to you
Eric for the hope okay and that is a
good question so for us with the number
of platforms we have mnemonic you see
that's being run daily the issue with 5
and 10 X rules is that we would generate
the points
or the flags maybe too quickly and
because we were already in the beginning
responding maybe too much to patient
issues that were happening we wanted to
eliminate that kind of flag when they
could actually be caused by just a shift
of a new bottle being opened up
something else happening so and being a
very minimal change but unfortunately
I'm clinics rules there they're not
really able to be refined a lot so it
just knows that's five times over the
mean and causes this flag rehearsal by
eliminating them that we kind of
eliminate some of the clutter the text
already kind of evaluate that above and
beyond I mean or below me when they're
looking at things but it just saved on
some of the issues so I hope that
answered a question I will pass it back
to you Nancy at this point thank you
that did answer the question it is
they're quite well I appreciate that
answer another question has come in and
it's one that would be very important to
me as a former lab director of a high
volume lab and that is as you noted
using patient moving averages is very
challenging when you have different
patient populations such as in patients
versus outpatients and taking into
account your emergency room and your
critical care units what approach do you
recommend to address the problem that
makes the patient moving average results
useful for each of these situations and
I would also add on to that how do you
address the problem of the aging of the
sample itself and that many of your
outpatient clinics might collect all of
your samples at six in the morning and
they get to your facility later in the
day so it's the type of patient and the
type of sample and how do you address
this with the patient moving averages
averages
okay that is a good question um and as i
can i would start discussing on the talk
itself that first of all starting with
audits is very important and that way
you can kind of watch and that would
audit not just for a day or two but for
several weeks maybe to an assay of
interest and then really get an idea for
how things are moving and that should
hopefully at that point and compass
enough of your patient changes
throughout the day or that can occur but
also some of your aging of the samples
and then you can try to start trying to
apply rules as we did with calcium and i
will tell you that it wasn't a perfect
start with that that being the very
first thing we did with moving averages
a try to play define like i said we had
a lot of overreaction but as we proved
upon our responses and other things and
refined are defined rsds and are you
know and our means and kind of tweak
with things we could kind of play with
it now the text when it comes to the
time of sample and those adjustments of
moving to outpatient work and stuff as
they see this occurring in knowing what
time of day it is this is where once
they become real informed about the
essay itself and what's occurring it
makes it easier for them to interpret
when things flag so they can quickly say
is they review through that a my i'm
really hitting out patients now because
in central link it's very easy to see
the location the age of the patient when
the sample was drawn so they can see
this quickly they can determine that
they're really hitting a batch of
samples from a clinic maybe that didn't
spend things in a timely fashion or
something in and then they can identify
it that it's occurring from that and not
from the instrument itself and then that
will interpret how they're gonna what
their response is going to be so it's
really something that where you start
isn't where you're going to be in a
month or two months later you're you're
definitely going to improve your ability
to respond to these things very quickly
the more you use them this alternate
back unit I think that's a very very
good answer that it is the it really is
a learning curve and you get farther up
on the curve more
as you use it more often so it will be
something that once the agony of initial
implementation is overcome that if the
text will become far more familiar with
how to utilize the results that they've
received and the differences in patient
populations we've just had a question
come in I we probably have partially
answered this but it was how many
samples do you believe you should use to
establish your QC ranges now I know that
most of our hospitals are different
sizes and we've talked about that but in
general if you have a basic metabolic
panel type analyte your sample size
would be such and if you have special
result special test your sample size
would be different so if you could just
maybe elaborate on that for this
questioner so the basic question is how
many samples do you use to establish
your QC range at which your keys um yes
I think that a size of institution and
everything and the test there again what
sa are you looking at it does play kind
of a role in that but I think smaller
institutions you know right now basic
sizes if we look at say 25 vs 50 and I
kind of put this in conjunction for us
i'm generating points so quickly that 50
as an average day for calcium it can be
impacted in that so in those afternoon
shifts you saw a 9.4 9.5 if I have a
patient come in that say is 12 is it
maybe there's an inpatient or outpatient
that's taking calcium supplementation
comes in then they have this value
that's elevated uh for some reason that
can be enough sometimes to cause that
shift of 95 to pump up to 96 and maybe
be a flag so it is something we want to
play with now if that was a 25-point
sample it would occur much faster and
more severely so it's definitely where
again with the idea of playing with
audit side so try a week
at 25 or maybe 10 or if you're in a
small institution see how I did what
those values how they move you're going
to see obviously but smaller patients
averages sites that things are going to
shift more severely so this is where it
also kind of plays into do you want it
to hold things right away when you see a
shift do you want it to just flag for
you so the bigger the size the smaller
the shift might occur and then it
becomes more of a flag but hey I just
might get your attention so it it's not
an easy fit it definitely each
institution has to play around a little
bit and audits are where you would want
to start and then you can kind of see
what your impact is so I know that's not
a perfect answer it is institutionally
institution but I'll pass the bag
contains its it is the appropriate
answer Eric because it is institution
dependent and it was very interesting
with the next question that came in is
actually about your institution and
hopefully not too personal but it says
how many IT personnel do you have in
your lab to do the audit and to help you
facilitate this I'll pass this back to
Eric that's actually a good question and
and I'll kind of and nothing gets IP
people here but we have no IT people in
our chemistry lab itself we have our our
pathology informatics people that write
about but one thing about middleware
what we've always kind of approach it as
is that we wanted it in the lab we
wanted to be able to react to it quickly
we didn't want to have to contact
somebody in another room or another part
of the building to try to look at things
so having little we're right there in in
the lab itself we do the audits or cell
phone on so these audits really only
take someone around 30 seconds to a
minute to to to generate so you can
quickly in Centrelink or in your
middleware system should be able to pull
up the instrument to the timeframe that
you want of all the patients for a
certain tests and then review through
them very quickly and so I have regular
text doing those audits the instrument
operators pull them up and literally can
look through 50 patients and in a minute
or two and just kind of evaluate what's
happening so that's the way we've kind
of always approached it we want those
texts this is where the idea of and
having them be informed of how things
are going to impact them make for better
decisions but for us we always kind of
found we've worked a little bit better a
little quicker if we didn't have
external I teen bolt and then I know
that sometimes flies in the face of what
other people do but for us in this large
institution it's worked very well it's
given us and me personally a much better
understanding of the middle player so
and has allowed us to I think utilize it
more than maybe some facilities do so I
hope that helps I think that you've just
shown us the real advantage of utilizing
middleware because then you do have
laboratory control and laboratory
knowledge of the work that's going on
and what the technologists are actually
doing so by enabling them to have better
control themselves they're also
achieving a higher educational level I
think that we have time for one more
question and this one's just come in
from the Sally bail and medical center
so if I can read it I didn't have time
to review it so sorry with all of the
adjustments to determine SD levels
during runs based on actual patient
populations isn't this nonparametric
when applied using decisions based on
population data and therefore ignoring
systemic error I think you just answered
the question but if you could anticipate
it through by looking at the systemic
error that might help a little bit more
Eric do you have any thoughts on that um
when we talk about systemic error and
that is really the the core of when we
start using moving averages what we
wanted to obtain so the idea is that
oh you want to see those values moving
and this is we're not getting too big a
point is that you want to see points
generate in some kind of timely fashion
but as you see points generating and
they start the initial flagging process
doesn't mean that you have to respond
right then you could set your SDS and in
such a way that you just want to bring
attention to them and then using normal
Westgard rules if you have more than one
failure then it could hold patients at
that point and say hey stop if you're
depending on the point size that you
have in place the level failure will you
know that severity issue can occur to a
point to get your appropriate systemic
fix in place so that that's why we run
as I kind of told you as we were talking
about the calcium's that I have set up
the responses that they'll run normal QC
right away we want to know immediately
they only have a flag do we have a
systemic problem once we get that QC
back and we determined that the
instrument is not requiring a
calibrations not requiring a blank that
it's actually just patient averages that
are moving then that takes off some of
that concern but we were definitely
going to pay attention for that next
point to come out and see is it moving
forward higher as you know how is it
responding and so it's really something
that while you're using moving averages
and this kind of nonspecific way you
only like in the case of clothes for the
calcium's with the trying to incorporate
in patient versus outpatient and stuff
you're still going to get the response
the movement that you see and in any
audit that you actually wrote as well
you can just pull it up anytime you want
and look at how things are moving in you
can see one instruments start tracking
away from another I mean doesn't mean
that's failing but if you just look at
it like a net chloride example and I see
that instrument number two is starting
to generate 107 108 these higher
slightly higher values then I'll go in
and run real QC so you don't have to
have it set per se to to a very specific
kind of flag you can sometimes just look
at it and in that kind of way and make
adjustments on the fly so I hope this
helps everybody
overall give them some idea I know it's
not may be perfect but it's definitely a
learning event as you go through it and
you'll feel much more comfortable more
you thank you since we just have a few
seconds left I'd like to give you a very
quick question Eric that's come in from
Barbara stout and it's I haven't thought
of it before but it is kind of
interesting where she says that back in
the 1980s moving averages were used in
hematology but not in chemistry she's
wondering since she's not in the lab
anymore when moving averages started to
be used in chemistry to you okay for us
as I said we've been using for about
seven years before then we really had it
not use them at all and I think even now
I think there's a fair number of
institutions that are not using them
very much so it's I think it's really
more as we move further along here as
the user clicking by that we're much
you're going to see a much higher use of
these the instrumentation the computers
everything is now and especially in some
cases automation itself is driving this
more I think in the chemistry side
because you can put out so many value so
fast that these kind of tools are more
useful so I don't know the specific time
frame but for us having leg assessment
seven years that's that's a very very
good answer I think as we see more
hospitals and laboratories utilizing
middleware that we will see more
utilization of moving averages I'd like
to pass this back to Vesna so that she
can give her thanks to our speaker today
Eric Fassbinder and any final comments
that vesna might have before we conclude
this webinar today personally I'd like
to thank you all for staying with us
today and for asking such an interesting
questions Eric thank you for me your
part
fascia here's vesna thank you nancy and
i would like to express our thanks to
Erik lass finder for a very educational
and interesting webinar which I think
has given our audience some very
practical information on how they can
get started with using patient moving
averages and Nancy thank you for being
such a excellent and graceful moderator
and finally thank you to our audience we
had some very thoughtful questions and I
hope that we have given you some content
that you can go back think about and
perhaps try and implement in your
laboratory